long gone are the days when only aging
upper class 52-year-old women got work
done now everyone is doing it especially
young people plastic surgery procedures
increased by 20% from 2019 until now
according to plasticsurgery.org uh the
same Source tells us that the Gen Z
crowd accounted for nearly 40% of all
nose jobs in the previous year and 25%
of all cheek implants because cheek
implants are apparently a thing
Meanwhile my generation Millennials seem
to be particular fans of buttock
augmentations and have accounted for
more than 40% of those his buttocks are
Sublime perhaps not surprisingly
liposuction is the most popular cosmetic
procedure of them all right right ahead
of breast implants and all of these
surgeries are being performed um more
often and they're starting at younger
ages